Hi, Doug. How are you?
Good, how's it going?
Great! Happy Friday!
Amen, sister. Amen.
I think that.
What's going on?
I think by Monday when I got here, I was waiting for Friday.
It's been a long week.
Yes, ma'am. Did you change your hair since I talked to you last?
Is it just different light, maybe?
We talked, yeah, we talked yesterday, right? It's a, it's a, yeah, it's the same, man.
I know.
Okay, is it is it different recently?
Yes, different.
Well, I don't always pick up on stuff the first time around. I mean, you know what I mean? Like it.
You're a man, right?
Yeah.
You said it. I feel discriminated against, but okay.
Glad that, glad that you're the one who's HR violating. Don't worry, I kicked, I already denied Natalie's no take care.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Yeah. Okay, thank God. I'm safe.
Safe, we're safe.
Safe, alright.
How many other, how many other note takers are in this meeting?
Who?
None, I don't think we have any more.
It's like I got them all.
Cool. Well, I like it. It looks cool. Sorry, I didn't notice yesterday, Andy.
It's okay. I forgive you. That's fine.
Whatever.
Go ahead, Ayra.
Ayra, what's good?
Yeah, sure. Thank you, Doug. How about you? How are you doing?
Oh, you know, it's Friday and it's Juneteenth, so like half the world is off, including my kids. So yeah.
It's kind of a light day.
Okay, that's good to hear that you and your family are doing great. Same with me. It's Friday, so I can't wait for the weekend. I'll start sharing my screen now. Thank you, everyone, for joining our monthly business review. Let me know once you can see my screen.
Yeah.
Got it.
Okay, thank you. So this is going to be for the month of May, Doug and Andrea. Agenda items are pretty much the same. I haven't changed any. Check in, this is for you, Doug. Anything you wanted to discuss here, challenges, opportunities?
Wins.
Just curious, Andy, I know you spoke yesterday with Shukla. How did that go?
Not yesterday, today.
Today, I'm sorry, Jesus.
Yeah, she was out yesterday. So we understand where she's coming from, why she's sick. She was able to provide medical certificate and all that, but we wanted her commitment and not having any more like sick leaves in the next three months, hopefully. We told her that
I mean, we know that sickness comes and go.
I mean, is there something medically going, is there something medically going on that we need to be aware of or, okay.
No.
Not really. So it's just those days. But then we wanted to make sure that, hey, we can't really stop you from getting sick, but we can do precautionary measures, right? You know, you're going to the gym, are you, what do you call this? Are you exhausting yourself way too much? Are you sleeping enough? Are you taking, I don't know, maybe vitamins because she's pretty thin.
Das.
So we wanted to make sure that we give her that so she has those precautionary measures so that we won't be having this type of issues. And I told her that, you know, you're new and if it's in your relationship, you wanted to make sure that you're reliable. And with you, I'm not saying that you're not reliable, but when
when you get sick every now and then and you're not there, someone else is taking that load up for you and that's not fair for them. So we just wanted to make sure that, you know, we get her commitment in the next three months that that attendance would be improving, which she agreed on.
I'm not saying that you can't get sick in the next few months. I can't say that.
Okay, well.
No, no, no, I think you guys know I'm not, I'm not a monster. I sometimes I am, but yeah, no, we don't, we don't want to, you know, it's a really delicate balance. I appreciate you guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
Taking care of it on this one, so.
Yep.
I have to deal with all of our other employees, and you have too, so I don't feel so bad.
Look.
That's true. But yeah, we are actually have like a way of actually looking at the trend of these people that are going to reach that. We have disciplinary actions here locally also. So that's part of that. But again, it's not about the disciplinary action right now. It's about what we're going to do.
No.
like moving forward and making sure that improves. So we're at it. Ayra and I are at it. So.
What?
Which one of you plays the bad cop?
This girl.
Good, you're back. The Iris, nice. OK.
Yep, she's always nice.
That's both interrogation techniques that are valid.
It works. I call pickup.
I'm also, I'm also the bad guy.
But until I could see, I used to at my old job, I used to be the good cop, but Steve is so nice that I had to turn into the bad cop.
We're just used to that.
That's what the story is with Ayra and I. Everybody just loves her. That's why I gotta be obviously bad cop. So.
I.
That's like.
Yeah, maybe in time I can go look up.
That's life.
Yeah.
All right, well, I appreciate it. That was really the only thing top of mind. Obviously, we were speaking to an additional service coordinator next week, so hopefully that'll go well.
Thanks, Doug.
Okay.
Maybe not, obviously.
Will do.
We are.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, cool. Do you need help from us with regards to your staff? Like additional staff and everything? We can help you out on that one whenever you need it.
No.
Perfect.
Okay, cool. Moving on to action tracker, I have three. So one and two, that's completed by you. Thank you so much for submitting the CSAT for me, as well as the Q1 NPS survey. We really appreciate you being proactive on submitting these kind of surveys.
And for the last one, this is the BrightGauge dashboard for Sheila. Actually, I need to reach out to AJ about this. Maybe early next week, I'll try to get some help from him if he got some free time. We can set up a meeting or he can like.
It's.
I can send him the KPIs that we need for dispatcher, and then if he's free, I'm sure he is, or is he like busy, busy lately?
He will make time for you. Include me on the request and we will make time for you. AJ is always busy, but this is important.
Yeah.
PH.
True, that's why I don't, I rarely reach out to agent because it's either busy, did not disturb, but I never caught him and available. That's why.
Yeah.
I mean, you can just add, I mean, just ask him to call you when he's available. He will. It's pretty good about that.
Okay.
Gotcha. I'll probably do that. You can do that next D guy or next week.
Okay, alright, cool.
Can you, do you use the feature in Teams where you can tag people for status notification changes or for not? Okay, so you stalk people too. Okay.
Yes. I usually see it. Hey, have they seen my message? Have they read it? Did they not reply?
Oh, but you can set alerts too when somebody goes from like green to yellow to red. And so, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Yes, exactly. When they're away, yeah.
Cool.
Okay. All right, moving on to performance analysis slide. For Service Das KPIs, that's all the same. Utilization trend for Nigel last month, it's pretty good. Our target, you all know that it's 80%.
There's just like a slight decline from last month, but that's just 1.75. He closed at 77%. And I did ask him about this. It's actually because of like the internal
tickets that he's been working on, like the Dell Support Services updates, the backups and everything, but because it's not billable. So that's why it's tracking the billable utilization or the percentage, but it's pretty good, 77%. So next month.
Yeah, and I mean, we were, I mean, you know, we're pretty loose on utilization and things like that. Really, checking the backup is, it's not being billed to an individual client, but it's a quote unquote billable activity where people are paying us for that. So.
Okay.
His numbers are fine, but if we need to move those stats a little bit, you know, things like that, I would I would be open to changing.
I don't think so. These numbers are good. So we'll see next month if it improved. I did ask him if we can check on other things on his end before we escalate this. I think this is workable. 77% is good. Yep.
Okay.
For sure, I have no problem with it. And I think it's probably even, you know, like I said, I consider backup work to be, you know, customer work, which is billable work. It's just not.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
Yes, it is.
Do you want Dog first to actually capture also the non-billable one and provide you categories for it? Because I feel like Nigel has those, like what is, because he does a lot of things. All right, he does a lot of tickets, billable tickets, he does a lot of non-billable, helping out this here and there.
Yeah, yeah.
So if you like capturing the non-billable and actually showing you what those non-billables are, would actually show a bigger picture of what he does on a daily basis. Would you like that?
I think that's great. And then hopefully, I mean, that will potentially identify some things that we, that you shouldn't be doing already.
Exactly.
Yep.
Perfect.
Sure, we can do that.
So we can do that. Next, service review. And then moving on to ticket closure trend and analysis. Our target for the ticket resolution rate is 80%. And then for the ticket closure, it should be 8 to 10. That's the ITBD by design recommended.
numbers, but for Nigel, he's doing pretty good. Like he closed at 10. That's his average resolved tickets for day 10. And for the average resolution rate, it's 87%. So he's hitting this KPI here.
Yeah.
the ticket resolution rate. Plus from the last review, we did see a big jump from the numbers for the ticket work and closed, 189 and then 164. So there were just like a slight dip for week two and three. That's because of his.
paid time offs and the holiday. But apart from that, he's doing very good. Questions from this slide?
No, I'm good.
Yeah, the guy rarely goes on lunch, man. I was like, Ayra, Ayra, and I keeps on telling you, Nigel, go on lunch, just get out of there. Exactly.
I have.
Yeah, make them, make them take a break, take a walk, do whatever.
And then he goes, it's really what I wanted to do. I just wanted to finish this off, la la la la. And I was like, come on, you're getting thinner already. Like, yeah, just an inside joke. Yeah, that guy is really, really debate.
Yeah, now I get it though.
Yeah.
Okay, this is for Sheila. I have included, I did include this slide so we can see the target that we're setting up for Sheila. That's triage, a curious rate, time to assign, which we did discuss during onboarding.
I did capture some of it. I did download a report from May. So we can see that the total tickets dispatched, total 157. Most of it were incident tickets. If we're going to look at the time to assign
or the dispatch response time, she's very good. 1.5 to 3 minutes, that's her average, according to my report. And this SLA result percentage, this is actually for the rest of the board. So I won't add this to her KPIs.
Plus, the missed response for Sheila, that's pretty clean. So, she was able to respond or assign tickets from the triage board without a miss. So, yeah, questions?
That looks good.
I have a question. I have a question for you, Doug. Do you get like annual reports from, I don't know, AJ and the rest of the team that, hey, there are some cases where in she was not able to triage things right away or who wasn't, she wasn't able to dispatch it right away or probably a wrong agreement, category, subcategory?
Yeah, more, not so much reports as anecdotally, you know, I hear about if trends are happening and things like that. In general, I hear good things about her. The thing that I would like to see, and I don't have good data around it, but what more advanced
Yeah.
Mmh.
kind of service coordinator work around really starting to ride the guys a little bit to actually, you know, keep things in the statuses that they are, that they should be closing stuff out and doing some of that kind of proactive, you know,
Mhm.
Mm.
Gotcha.
just kind of maintenance of what's going on. Same thing, putting a little more thought into, you know, kind of reworking and, you know, how tickets should be described, you know, kind of that first step of, you know, yeah, like the level of detail that gets handed off.
Summary.
Mmh.
Um...
It of course, I think the quality can vary depending on how many calls are coming in, which is what I expect. So that's why it's hard to judge because sometimes it's like quick ticket, quick ticket, quick ticket, quick ticket, because that's what you got to do, right? But I would also like her to be thinking more about the higher level. And we have a weekly dispatch meeting where we kind of
Mhm.
Mhm, mhm.
talk to all of the folks that are in that function. And a lot of what we talk about is like, you guys run the company. It's okay for you to reach out and to tweak somebody if they're not doing what they're supposed to do. It's something obviously I'm really comfortable with. Like when I'm in that room, I'm like, put your time in, it's, you know, it's non-negotiable, you know, I'm much more firm about it.
Mhm.
Yes, yeah.
True.
I think Nigel and Sheila both are like super polite and deferential and like willing to like take like, oh, I'll do it later as like, okay, that was the answer. So I just want them to be a little more assertive internally with our people and be like, no, update your statuses or I can't do my job.
You know, so I think that that comes with time and comfort too. But something I'm trying to encourage out of both Sheila and Nigel is like, you guys run the show, man. So don't feel bad about speaking up.
Yeah.
We all answer to that.
Gotcha. All right.
Okay, we're going to build the plan around that to improve on that side of the fence because if you're a dispatcher, you actually have to be on top of the things that are assigned and can be moved on the next stage just in case a priority comes in. And definitely if the ticket has no notes or
has no time entries and probably the time entries that has been put is in the correct tab. Usually this is the issue when it comes to ticket hygiene, right? The resolution was added as a resolution, even though that's part of the troubleshooting, not the actual resolution. So those are the things that I feel like is happening currently. And soon enough, if they build that confidence in.
Right.
Again, just like what he said, being assertive, maybe we can have them own, or when you're a dispatcher, we can have them own SLO, maybe soon enough. We can make sure that they follow up, they escalate, and they reach out to these people, hey, what's happening on this ticket? It's been a while, la la la la.
Yeah.
those type of issues. At least the ball is rolling. It's not stopping. It's still continuous. So let me think about how that's going to work. I'll probably just have to do side by side with Sheila because, yeah, once upon a time, I was once a charge and dispatch.
when I was in the previous company, previous, previous company, when I was young. So that's like a...
When I was young, please.
That was like my bread and butter dog. I was like, people hate me because I was just a, I was a dispatcher. Anyway, so.
No.
No, it's that my best technician started at dispatch and they understand the role and they, you know, just because they do it the right way. And you get it. I don't have to preach to you because, you know, assertiveness is a big part of it. And I'm always happy to be the hammer. And if somebody isn't listening, I'll come down on them.
Process.
Mhm.
Okay.
But it's really like...
Mhm.
see how far you can go and then apologize later. You know, like I'm okay with it.
Yeah.
It's easier that way. But yeah.
So especially when other people, my thing is when somebody else isn't doing their job and it's making your job harder, you need to speak up, right? And so,
True.
Ask for help.
Yeah, no, I think we're good on that. I appreciate it.
Gotcha. Uh, we'll work something out. I'll work something out along with the Ayra.
How about when Sheila calls in, you just fill in on those days and you can be with the person that was it?
K.
Sure, I can do that. You can, you can pay me. I know you can pay me.
Boom. She said yes, bring the note taker back in.
Yeah.
I can do that. Anyway, I'll make sure that I work with her sometime next week so that we can understand that better. And if a training is necessary, I would do that. I think I still have my trainings in the past, so.
Kour.
I can share that with her.
I used to have a young gal who worked with me and we used to literally do assertiveness training with her because she was so meek that we would like, we would do like role play calls where I would be mean, I would be mean to her on the phone and make it like, no, like you got this.
Aww.
PH.
But.
Wow.
Ahh.
Those days. All right. Thanks, Doug. Ayra, sorry.
Sorry, yeah, keep going, keep hitting next or well this will go or you'll never get rid of me.
No worries.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, let's move on to CSAT. This is for the whole May. So we got three out of three. These are all the companies that responded to the survey. Neil Ross, RVMF, Hinner, and
We got a lot on June, so I'll probably have to check on that. But the response rate, I'm not sure if we can get that. But I can ask AJ about it, because I'm not sure if this is low, the three out of three for the month of May, considering he's been...
closing a lot of tickets. So I did took it out from the bribe page.
I think, I mean, it's, we're a little low as far as our response. I just looked at these numbers, but he's right on par with our other people.
Vaid.
And with, and what I see too is the actual comments too. He gets about, you know, 1/3 of his people actually say something. I have started, and I'm sorry that you babies can't see this, but in our weekly meetings, I do an interpretive reading of anybody who gave comments. So we'll keep that going.
Okay.
As if I were the, as if I were the customer.
Okay, cool. So moving on to Build It Live. Are you coming?
I don't know; I haven't decided yet.
Let's help, let's help you.
I asked him. I asked him. I asked him on the chat. He has seen it. He did not reply to me until I called him yesterday.
I know, Andy asked me about it.
And set.
I don't know. I know.
Why?
Yeah, you should come down.
Not coming.
Because I don't, because I don't know, I haven't decided yet.
You should.
Yeah.
I do want to go, but I just haven't decided. So I have to work out my next two trips to New York, at least. I don't know if I'm going to go earlier in the summer or later. And then AJ, in his eternal foolishness, is getting married this fall. So I'm coming back again, like on a set date in the fall.
Mhm.
So, I'm not sure.
Oh, congratulations.
My marriage is overrated.
Come on!
This has been someone who's been married almost 20 years.
It's this is recorded, so I can't say anything again.
I love my wife, and she is great.
Yeah.
I bet.
is the best. I try, I do try and talk people out of both getting married and having kids because it's a big commitment. And so you should be able to overcome my objections.
Yep, and that's why I have three dogs, so...
They're smart, smart lady.
Anyway, so I was told that, you know, Jersey's filling up, the hotel in Jersey is filling up really, really fast during these days. So please make your arrangements and book your time and attend the lift.
Right.
You too will be the first to know if I, when I sign up, that will be.
Okay. All right. Are you going to bring anybody with you? You have BOGO, man. You can bring them free.
Ecstatic.
I don't know.
Yes, I do remember that. Yeah, if I come, I'll probably bring somebody, probably a New Yorker.
Yep.
Easy that way. All right.
Okay, that's settled then. We're looking forward to seeing you there, Doug. It's going to be a lot of parties, events, and etc. So, yeah. Moving on to IT by Design products, you're already aware of this. Just let us know if you need any of it. Way forward.
Sounds good.
This coming July 3rd, do you need our guys?
Nope.
Okay, fantastic. I did reach out to Nigel and he's already aware that you don't have work on Independence Day. Plus, the next service call, I would like to ask you if we can book one hour time this coming July 17th. That's going to be our first quarterly business review.
Yeah.
And we're going to be discussing the Q2 scores and KPIs.
And can Steve join?
Was that working?
Yes.
Yeah, I was just looking at that.
You said it's the July 17th.
Yes, 17th, 1pm to 2pm.
Yes. Can you send out like a fresh, like a fresh reminder, a fresh invite that isn't this one so that we get additional people on it to kind of notice? And I would say let's invite both Steve and AJ, please.
Okay, I'll get that working by maybe next week. I'll do that.
Anyways, one hour is good, right?
Okay.
Yes, we could do that.
Fantastic. How about you, Andrea? Are there any conflicts?
July 17th, once. Okay. All righty. Open Q&A. Any questions from anyone?
When was the... I'll make it work. I'll make it work anyway. Don't ask me.
I think I'm good. I love it. I always let it fly freely, so...
Um...
We'll be meeting each other Monday, Doug, regarding that invite that I sent you. So we'll discuss that opportunity, just, you know, speak with her. And just in case, you know, you weren't able to, you know, like her or proceed with her, then you have different candidates anyway under the pipeline.
Yeah.
So, but at least we have a, we have a significant career path for Nigel. So this is not just for, you know, adding up people into being a service coordinator, but to be sure that we can have Nigel work on a lot more.
Sure.
In the next coming months, so...
Good. Okay. And I see the resumes and the invites, so perfect.
Yes. Gotcha. All right. Any questions? No, but.
I appreciate you both.
Thank you. I'll stop sharing my screen now, and so it's Friday, it's weekend. Enjoy both of you. I hope you have a wonderful time with your own families. OK.
Thank you.
Likewise.
Bye. Enjoy. Yes.
And dog spice.
Take care, and and dog dogs, that's and that is family.
Yeah, exactly. So I want to make sure, clarified.
Yeah.
Mine, mine, Andy just quickly got into a scrap with a groundhog recently, so we're going to be doing some.
How is he?
She's fine. I have a pretty big dog. She's like 40ish pounds. So, but she has no killer instinct. She only wants to play with wild animals. And so if she like encounters a deer and I live out in the woods, so she sees **** every day. And so it's like, if she sees something like a woodchuck or a raccoon or something, she'll be like,
She Okay.
Aww.
Oh, no.
We'll play, let's play, and these things will be like...
What?
Yeah.
No.
Ready to fight her.
Perfect.
Ohh.
So, yeah, the joys.
That's adorable and scary at the same time.
Vaid.
Yeah.
The joys of living in the country.
Yeah. All right. Well, thanks, ladies.
A lot of adventure.
Take care.
Bye.
Thank you, bye.